goldman sachs the wall street bank with
over two trillion dollars in assets
under management they are an officially
the very first major wall street bank to
conduct an over-the-counter crypto
transaction on behalf of their clients
this is a big deal because it shows that
financial institutions and banks are
only going to continue to adopt this
brand new technology and all of these
digital assets now here's exactly what
they're doing goldman sachs has
partnered with galaxy digital one of the
leading crypto organizations galaxy
digital by the numbers they have over
690 institutional trading counterparties
they have added 43 new relationships in
q3 last year they support over 100
digital assets on their trading platform
and they also provide liquidity for
goldman's first cme bitcoin futures
trade last year now we've got two quotes
from the co-president of galaxy digital
explaining why exactly this is so
important the first states that this
trade represents the first step that
banks have taken to offer direct
customizable exposures to the crypto
market on behalf of their clients then
damien went on to explain that the
options trades are much more
systematically relevant to markets
compared to cleared futures or other
exchange-based products at a high level
that's because the implications of the
risk banks are taking on they're
implying their trust in crypto's
maturity to date now many of these
instruments are somewhat exotic they're
unique to financial markets in the
legacy world but what you at home need
to understand is that the banks get it
they understand not only where the
asymmetry is but they also are listening
to their clients
more and more wall street banks are
going to get in the game that's good for
bitcoin that's good for cryptocurrencies
and ultimately that's good for the
people who already recognize this
they're either building in this space
they're working in this space or they're
simply holding the assets wall street's
on the way and they're just getting
started hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time